hey this is precious show Walker
here's a fun little puzzle ABCD
multiplied by 4 is equal to dcba
each letter is a different digit from 0
to 9 and you have to solve for the value
of each letter
I think everyone who suggested the
puzzle to me
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
so where do we begin
let's start out by solving for the
letter A
notice that 3000 times 4 is equal to
twelve thousand which is a five digit
number
but we need the result to be a four
digit number
so it's not possible for a to be a value
that's three or larger the result would
be too big
so we need a to be less than three which
means a is equal to 0 1 or 2.
then we have D times 4 is equal to a
so we have a number times four is equal
to a which means that a is an even
number so we know that a is equal to
zero or two
so now let's eliminate the possibility
of zero
we'll look at the times table for four
so we need the last digit to be equal to
zero so D is equal to zero but we've
already used zero
so we could have 20 where the last digit
is zero and that would mean d is equal
to five so if a were Zero D would be
five
but then what's the largest number we
could have if the leading digit is zero
it would be nine eight five multiplied
by four and that results in three
thousand nine hundred and forty so it
doesn't get up to five thousand so we
know a equals zero D equals five cannot
be a possibility so we eliminate it and
that means a must be equal to two
now from here if a is equal to 2 we'll
go ahead and pull up our times table
again and we need the units digit to be
equal to two so one possibility is 12
and then we would have D is equal to
three the other possibility is 32 and
then we would have D is equal to eight
so D is either three or eight
now two thousand times four is equal to
eight thousand so we know that D cannot
be equal to three that'll be too small
so we must have D is equal to eight
so a is equal to 2 and D is equal to 8.
we can now transform the problem into an
algebraic expression
ABCD is the same as a times 1000 plus b
times 100 plus c times ten plus d we
want to multiply this by four and the
result will be D times a thousand plus c
times a hundred plus b times ten plus a
we'll now go ahead and work through we
know that a is equal to 2 and D is equal
to 8 so we substitute in
we then simplify this
and then we can cancel out and group
like terms
so let's simplify this we have 8 000 on
both sides then we have 30 minus two so
that'll be equal to Thirty then we bring
over 400 B minus 10B and already C minus
100c so we get 390b minus 60c plus 30 is
equal to zero we divide both sides of
the equation by 30. we get 13B minus two
c plus one is equal to zero
now we might as well solve for b so we
get B is equal to two c minus 1 all over
thirteen so we know that 2C minus 1 has
to be divisible by 13.
so we only need to work through a few
possibilities
so if 2C minus 1 is equal to zero we
could have two c minus one is equal to
13. two c minus 1 is equal to 26. let's
work out some values for C so in the
first case C would be equal to 0.5 we
can't have that second case C is equal
to seven that could be a possibility in
the next case we have C is equal to 13.5
and any further multiple will be larger
so that'll be larger than a single digit
we can't have that therefore we have C
is equal to seven which means
substituting in we get that b is equal
to one
so we figured it out a is equal to 2 D
is equal to eight C is equal to seven
and B is equal to one we'll just go
ahead and substitute this into our
original puzzle and we do in fact verify
this is a solution
2178 times 4 is equal to eight thousand
seven hundred and twelve and that's the
answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
thank you